[Music]
[Music]
well everyone's sleeping
the others weird engine noise coming
from my engine which is where most
engine noises originate
you just read like I love it here in
Philly and Philadelphia's more like say
something and if you see something
continue saying something because y'all
are always talking that I'm autistic
I think it's fine that Tanner is a white
person's name hasn't that white you
white [ __ ] I should be like hey
this is my Mexican friend tanner
that's my Blackman tennis agent woman
I've like there's such a hot [ __ ] in
America but backbone we're throwing them
away
don't forget about that a lot of their
ladies I don't understand I think the
Asian women are created me [ __ ] okay
you gotta have an Asian man [ __ ] to
create a beautiful Asian woman I'm a
crucial part of the sexy process please
stop trying to skip me so why don't you
try something new you goddamn racist no
they're very useful town and good I'm
from New York and Philadelphia is very
similar to New York you guys stuff the
same shitty weather is a shitty
proximity to New Jersey pretty much the
same age doormen are soaked under there
like a pig sweater in the washing
machine everything
oh talking diksa you know macho man
rejoice your hands together
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys thank you good to be here
I've also south for me you know so you
could say I'm a southerner there's only
two things I like in this world keep
hopping shouldn't commies I'm a crucial
part of the sexy process I love women I
think they're so beautiful I can't help
staring at them
because to be a woman is like a
beautiful sunset that can yell at you
they're like they're like a waterfall
that can call the cops
we can't take a picture even though you
kind of want to just so you can look at
it later and my hugging pool was this
one girl was like did you know that my
vagina is a doodie printer because it
can make a baby I'm like that's not even
accurate your womb is the 3d printer
your vagina is the tray
[Music]
it's not even a very good 3d printer
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors takes nine months to print and
the whole time it's printing is
complaining hey there's a saying that
not any trays that night I mean I think
better shitty but I don't have to [ __ ]
them so I got a good parking spot
tonight everything I need right here
you´d Philadelphia cuz it's all on this
car the best part is I don't have to
pack I just had to drive they even have
to clean up
I just left everything a mess I
basically woke up and moved my whole
life to Philadelphia and eventually
Miami there's some birthday stuff do it
like a duck please keep those hands
clapping all that love in the room
thank you guys gonna be here my name is
Hans I hope you can understand my
English and it's study a bit in high
school a lot someone came up to me and
as I did so many of your jokes are Asian
jokes you only talk about being Asian
it's sort of hat I was like damn I know
I should write more jokes about being
Hungarian there's a billion of us I
think that's what the coronaviruses you
know H always try to supply his level
there's a billion of one thing you're
gonna have to call the heart trim it
down I know it's crazy
she said that I'm gonna get cancelled I
saw a truck and on the side of it I said
you can't rent me for $30 an hour and I
was like damn that truck makes twice
what I make I could be doubling my
salary if I was a truck right now I
don't even have a carburetor the real
reason I'm a and reang supporter is
because I think poor people are
disgusting I am on my way to Fergie's
they just have an assemble up on the
bell of Liberty Alexander Graham Bell
once said let me call you
anymore about liberty when that bell
rings you're gonna pick up the phone and
I'm gonna have invented the Liberty Bell
Telephone Company this is actually the
original Bell they used to record the
first telephone bell ringing ring ring
ring adherent that's called freedom
thank you for your wonderful invention
and for making the freedom possible
let's make long-distance call us and get
charged a lot for it I was I was
thinking about it tonight I was like
should I talk about it all right I'll be
your host this evening
and coming up to the stage now I want to
hear it let me hear it
thank you guys gonna be here love love
and life love traveling through America
in a van doing open mics you know open
mics although they're fun they're not
real comedy real comedy is about
pandering to tourists no no this this
joke wasn't I good by putting a lot of
personal details could've written a joke
in an apartment buddy
anyways that's a tweet it did pretty
well yeah that was great
and that wasn't too busy Friday the
media lady zoom in you're next to me
[Applause]
super funny format account get up
Rohan's yeah my name is Hans and I know
what I look like but I'm not that into
anime tell me about your favorite
episode
it's just how I was born
but here's the thing the women that are
sexually attracted to me all seven of
them really into anime so I guess I'm
pretty into anime now too
I forgot I have wresting anime face
[Applause]
constantly cosplay I am a sapiosexual so
I'm looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding a game tracker
[Applause]
like a woman is in the closet
yeah holy [ __ ] you're wearing that
tonight okay I can figure this out I go
on dates like sorry I look like this but
my sis just [ __ ] a white dude right
now and I think it's very impressive if
you bring it to play and I think it's
very impressive if you performed in a
play but if you've written and performed
the play I don't think that's very
impressive that's just a crazy person
doing one of the [ __ ] they want to do
that's someone being like anyway it's
here some jokes that have written and
performed I think capitalism is great if
you want to do it but don't make
everyone play your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
play take away our house if she loses a
lot of Americans will say communism
never works that's if we didn't spend
billions of dollars and kill billions of
people to make sure it won't work
[Applause]
remember the war in Vietnam we're pretty
anxious about it now warning Tommy the
never works because whatever people
control the means of production they're
democratically like the leaders
mysteriously died and the small rubber
crew finds automatic weapons and law
permitting themselves
are you stabilizing yourself way to
stabilize I have a big supporter of
Andrew yang I can't wait till you know
inking takes off I think in the future
where I can eliminate gangster's
paradise so guys just hanging out here
at this parking lot of a casino right
next to the punch sign in Philly where I
will soon do 25 minutes the stand-up
comedy for real audience members do the
thing that you don't know that most
people don't know that's really hard to
know about van life unless you do it
it's really hard to find level ground
you always some sort of angle like even
now this is not an angle it's slightly
tilted so it's down that way and uphill
that way so it's really hard to find
level ground cuz usually streets are
like they're like this like that they're
like a like a mound and it's curved at
the way that meets the sidewalk it goes
down for some reason I don't know maybe
there's some streets out there that are
completely level but most streets are
curved and if you're parked then you're
you're just sort of tilted all the time
but this is [ __ ] beautiful is like
constructed by the Egyptians and I just
had a great madis of open mikes
just slumming it hard hitting these mics
well not the casino anymore not at the
beautiful parking lot full of a girl
this is where I'm [ __ ] at look at
this [ __ ]
you got a dirty-ass underpass overpass
I'm under an overpass but this is a very
quiet bridge I don't know why they
[ __ ] constructed this thing it
doesn't sound like anyone's on it on it
but maybe it's double paned I don't know
how to build bridges oh the reason why I
had to move is because there was a leak
in my roof I went upstairs to the second
floor to the roof to the patio and I
sprayed this flex seal [ __ ] that's
supposed to work so hopefully that will
do the trick
it's coming out of this area right here
slept under the bridge and it turns out
it's like a subway or train and they
just don't run at night
I was enjoying it for a little bit but
then it got too loud so now then I went
to the grocery store I never
- oh I love about being on set in New
York is that these parking garages exist
I got my chicken quarters some Teddy
Grahams and sliced peaches faithful EBP
thank you everyone keep paying your
taxes helping me live which is a penance
to print a millionaire so don't get mad
at me baby I'm mad
dear money so baby I'm headed to the
Philadelphia punchline you do a quick 25
satoru Hey he's down from New York City
as well and he has over 100 followers on
Facebook pretty impressive
please give a warm welcome to Hans Kim
everybody even a hug from you
good to be here guys how you guys doing
well okay I think I'm doing better than
you I'm gonna be here in my name is Hans
kid that's my real name my parents named
me Hans because it didn't want kids at
school to make fun of me for having an
Asian name so they gave me a German one
instead foolproof plan I flew right
under the radar then no idea I was Asian
they say prison don't drop the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
don't pick up the soap they could drop
this myself as you want
it's the bending over where they really
get you if you don't drop this up you're
still gonna get raped this has been a
really clean hands all the napkins what
were these rape is like I want to get
that kid but he never drops the soap
does he have a butthole big cops have a
hand fetish that's why they're always
like hey let me see your hands
nice they'll make the touch
but then by your butt just getting off
on us now that's so rude I saw a YouTube
video or Tony Hawk was like I used to
keep boarding to express my emotions but
I've never needed a skateboard to do
that you know I've never been arguing
with the next have been like a bully on
my skateboard I can show you how I
really feel when you talk to your ex it
makes me feel like this I don't think I
could ever [ __ ] a dude sorry sir oh yeah
I've never looked at a beautiful woman
and it was like well she's gorgeous but
is there a version of her that's bigger
and hairier and that's less kindness I
want to put that on my butthole never
happened straightest [ __ ] please believe
me
my dad doesn't I hate it when women
called me a premature ejaculator okay
first of all premature to who I can't
write at the perfect time when I felt
amazing
takes maturity do not please yourself
that's the best way to be sexy
mathematically please ladies not all at
once
calm down over there of course I'm not a
racist I'm a minority how could I be
impossible I don't even see race how we
smell it I love riding the subway down
the subway school but I hate it when
homeless people beg for change on the
subway so what I usually do is I switch
cars that way I can say no to them over
and over again here's the thing Mara was
gonna do it and then he kind of
chickened out here they hold my bag yeah
I just have water bottles and that's
what me sick that I gotta hear right
here which is super useful and then the
bong is right over here the silicon Bob
everybody sorry
you saw the job at a sushi restaurant
where most of my job was to occasion
[Music]
guys I have not been doing my thorax at
all recently it just keeps growing and
growing much like to this open mic list
all right next up we've got a man
hailing from New York City who's on its
way to DC stop by our town for some laps
and fun give it up for Hans Kim thank
you guys it's good to be here I'm not a
communist but I do support any policies
that Republicans consider communism
which
whenever two more people gathered to do
something nice the Black Panther movie
was a great movie because gave black
children here what they could I got to
and not just someone like Martin Luther
King jr. and Malcolm X right it's up in
to Rosa Parks or Thurgood Marshall
George Washington Carver there's a fake
person that dressed like a cannon
congratulations what are they gonna come
out with a yellow Panda huh I give me a
fun of a lot because Asian people eat
dogs which I understand can be very
shocking because in America dogs are
treated like family members but in Asia
we treat our family members like family
members we had a little tradition we
have where instead of buying an animal
we love our grandma unless she's in the
big ago which makes it different River
yeah don't treat her well better I need
to attend a woman who's really to yoga
and choke sex and I was like do you
enjoy breathing or not
[Applause]
[Music]